à 27 ans
d'autres à 34
je pars en partie tenues d'équitation va
dire ben c'est avantageux pour voir les
formes pour voir un petit peu la
silhouette des filles s'agit pas de
photos de moi
j montre moi je vais courir un peu moi
je vais te regarder courir
tu veux servir encore moi le problème je
suis une petite bouche ils n'osaient pas
ce problème là
où je peux me très bon avec athias et
natasja en blonde dans la famille je
crois que le moule de fabrication est
pas malade
[Musique]
de tous
disent que ça va vous alors l'algérie
est
ce que vous trouvez ça choquant oui moi
je vous vois déjà le concept même de
l'émission il pousse les hommes à se
comporter avec les femmes original c'est
vrai déjà dès le début on demandait à
deux femmes de dormir chez un homme
qu'elle ne connaisse pas où j'en suis
femme d'avoir deux hommes qui dominent
et ça se passera par avec les femmes en
suit une femme de recevoir deux femmes
voilà presque elle est amoureuse de deux
femmes oui mais ça ne se passe pas
pareil ensuite je connais un terreau qui
s'écoute et moi écoutez moi ensuite je
trouve que ça banalise la polygamie il
ya plein d'hommes qui se baladent firman
on l'a vu dans les séquences avec deux
femmes et qui ont des vagues là dessus
et pour que là dessus at il accusé par
ce nouveau tout ça et
ensuite à la fin on voit bien qu'on
pousse presque
avoir des ratés des relations avec les
hommes parce qu'on sait que ça fait des
séquences dans les missions sinon je
trouve ça
[Rires]
c'est pas le vegan qui parle c'est le
sais c'est pas le mec que j'ai vu dans
le jacuzzi salle
arena c'est peut-être un autre regard
nicolas pernikoff ça vous choque enfin
ça me choque et 2 qu'on le coup pas au
montage je trouve ça choquant c'est ça
mais je suis désolé est-ce que vous avez
vu comment la femme est traité pire ils
sont qu il est en train de draguer
l'entrée
par amaury du moule et voeckler héros
bien il
pourrait couper ce genre de passage
c'est non s'il vous plaît je veux dire
oui là je me dis oui pour l'instant
tient castaldi non mais franchement on
parle sans cesse du respect qu'on doit
avoir envers les femmes passant c'est au
fait qu'il faut faire attention à bien
se comporter à pas être malotru à faire
des choses sales des femmes et là on l'a
dans tout ça et comme à l'autre ou
d'autres mais mais mais mais c'est à
vous donner un bon exemple
franchement je vous le dis c'est
extrêmement choquant mais ça me choque
ça me fait passer comme son vainqueur
dégradant à face à serra récemment en
avant et c'est nul voilà je vous dis je
c'est absolument honteux pour l'image de
la
que ce qu'ils disent oui c'est que des
hommes laissez-moi vous mais alors nous
dévoile le des hommes ah oui
j'ai poitrine mais
vincent on a honte d'être un homme
dégradant il est vigueur les machos il
va la séduire pour passer une nuit avec
elle et ils âge est
arrêté à mathieu laissez moi parce que
c'est grave faut d'abord l'occasion
l'âge est de manière honteuse tout en
relevant sa soeur dans l'émission
c'est honteux c'est honteux franchement
mais tu devrais passer les bornes mais
tu vraiment guérir avec les gars vous
êtes vraiment les rois de l'ipo comédien
gilles parce que j'étais honnête mais va
au delà quoi peut décemment moins de 3
mois non je leur ai pas parlé comme ça
le roi des chacals je t'appelle comme ça
le roi les chacals alors franchement tu
vas me dire que t'as jamais relooker les
fesses d'une femme non je parle de les
découper les messieurs l'émission
c'est la filière lycée à l'antenne
aujourd'hui on parle le respect de la
femme la lcb à les exercer ces femmes ne
sont pas pleins de
messages et kevin c'est chiant parce que
je trouve vraiment hypocrite nicolas
parce que justement c'est une émission
qui se dit de montrer la réalité est en
réalité et ben oui ça se passe comme ça
et si les femmes se sont offusqués bas
ce moment là elles le disent elles n'ont
pas l'air offusqué du tout elles le
vivent très bien et il ya un moment
donné aussi on peut plus rien faire plus
rien dire c'est qu'on a car souvent
natacha et tu n'as pas vu avec des
étoiles au magazine elle vient d'en
parler avec contact avec reconnaît
natacha quand elle a vu sinon va
bien
ça marchait
jenny j'ai pas dis oui ninon déjà
ces problèmes je pense qu'une façon si
quand vous avez bien écouté dans son
introduction des au départ il cherchait
une dame parce que c'est un monsieur qui
a déjà une femme dont il a pris la
petite jeune fille c'est ma fille élève
sondages et mac ça fait quelque chose
non merci sans partage il savait bien
que c'est pas et cette petite dame la
talent et lui il cherchait quelqu'un l'a
dit mais pour mon fils qui voit les
défis tout cas pas une enfant et une
dame m'a vraiment dans son à l'autre
dame était vraiment dans son art by your
eyes on sait ce que je pense moi ne sera
jamais la bière arrivait à tenir ils le
veulent arriver chez belle-maman ben
c'est vrai que c'était plutôt la belle
moment faille qui prend au lieu de la
fille parce que ça correspondait plus à
dater d'hier bamba le moule et tout ça
je pense qu'il a tu ne t'es pas obligé
de venir tiens je crois que ce soit sur
il assuré sur moi ils sont jolis thierry
cui jaffe
qui a très bien résumé la situation et
wish upon même il a raison parce que
j'avais la vue nous a dit vous avez dit
pas est il écrit comment il a dit depuis
le début bakshi et ouais donc voilà mais
oui oui ça m'a personnellement je trouve
que ce projet je n'aime pas cette
émission mais je sais aussi en
comportement me sied tout sans nullement
j'en ai marre de ça moi avec mon gros
test et je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec elie et je pense que vous messieurs
vous êtes complètement mal à briser
parce qu'on est dans ce sens pour vous
et construire les mecs ça et patrons et
à la traque dans toutes les émissions de
la moindre masculinité toxiques alors ce
type qui se comporte comme ça parce que
c'est normal parce qu'il envie de
regarder le cul d'une année c'est la vie
je mets tous ces problèmes ne l'a plus
on vous dire à quel point tout devient
hypocrite c'est les 2 plus à toi que
18,6
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mexes et regarde le coût de ce fait je
suis d'accord avec vous je suis d'accord
et mot sur cette première phrase sur les
deux là mais ça déconne à déconner non
mais il faut le ramadan ne jamais dire
jamais couché avec une fille juste pour
couche avec j'aimerais
te plaît
et
c'est vrai ça calme toi non mais c'est
le bonhür guillaume il a eu un coup de
coeur il a eu envie elle a eu envie d'y
lancer son parfum elle héberge
déjà le prénom quand même
il a quand même besoin de coucher avec
pour se rencontrer l'entente elle est
trop belle je mets les rebelles est trop
jeune
shérif a tout compris on hamm est revenu
de loin on ira chez elle il se rend
compte que la jeune fille mais en fait
elle fait des selphy tout le temps à
l'une de ses passions que c'est pas son
délire
un moment tu as peut-être à des désirs
et alors là et consomme je vous connais
tous vont alors je suis célibataire et
habite mais aux notions ne m'étais pas
là dedans un merci kelly les douves et
nice il avait une main font pas mal mais
je ne suis plus avec
foi de jacques chirac combien de
secondes à faire je suis célibataire
je suis comme vous tuez vous mais
demandez-vous sortie
bon bah c'est celle que j'aime tant mais
vous savez qu'on veut plus aujourd'hui
des jeunes comme ça j'aime le côté vrai
homme qui déteste ça côté homme dur là
jo sauveur qui perd pas donc ça
forcément c'est un républicain soir
total voilà si oui on est en train de
décrire et vous avez vous géré avait une
émission de sexe de cul c'est pas du
tout ça l'amour et dans l'ue mais il ya
aussi lui aussi serré
entre temps ça on doit trouver l'amour
est prête on doit trouver l'amour et à
la place de ça il ya des jeunes chercher
les enfants
mais aussi le sexe mais moi aussi je
sais c'est pas le sexe je cassais 2
allez c'est bon et chérir ce qu'on
pensait pas des spectateurs c'est pas
resté deux heures fattu
44% ouaïl value pas et non à 56 % c'est
plutôt partagés là